نجتمع اليوم
في وقت حرج لكوكبنا
في عالمنا
يواجه تحديات معقده ومن اهمها تغيير
المناخ الذي اصبح
يؤثر على الاستقرار والامن في العالم
وبما اننا لا نملك الا ارضا واحده
من الضروري ان واحد جهودنا
لمعالجه هذا التحدي من خلال العمل المناخي
الذي ينظر اليه بكونه فرصه للابتكار
وايجاد الحلول وتنويع الاقتصاد
الحضور الكريم ان دوله الامارات تعتبر
مزودا ومسؤولا للطاقه وسوف تستمر في هذا
الدور طالما كان العالم بحاجه الى النفط
والغاز
وبحكم
الجيولوجيا فان النفط والغاز في دوله
الامارات ايها الساده ضمن الانواع الاقل
كثافه كربونيه في العالم والحمد لله
وسنواصل للتركيز على خف الانبعاثات
في هذا القطاع
وهذا ليس بجديد
فقد وجه الوالد المؤسس الشيخ زايد طيب
الله ثراه
بوقف عمليات حرق الغاز من عده عقود
وارسى ركائز استدامه في دوله الامارات
حفاظا على البيئه والموارد الطبيعيه
وسيرا على هذا النهج بدانا منذ عقود العمل
على تنويع اقتصانا
وبناء القدرات في الطاقه المتجدده ونظيفه
لتحفيز النمو الاقتصادي والاجتماعي
المستدام
وكانت الامارات اول دوله في المنطقه
تعلن مبادره استراتيجيه لتحقيق الحياه
المناخي
بحلول عام 20 50